alors bonjour autour de la planète c'est
donc l'équipe de tam-tam canada pour le
moment trois personnes ici devant un
mois une quatrième qui fait office de
maître de cérémonie mais il y aura deux
autres invités mystères qui vont se
glisser à travers notre émission
aujourd'hui je révèle au moins ce secret
je pourrais en dire plus mais non ce
n'est pas je peux payer pour ça alors
autour de la table paloma martinez
bonjour j fn qui était avec moi durant
une bonne partie de la semaine à
l'équipe française on a ici
marie claude simard qui est notre
webmestre ici à ercis internationale
bonjour et services latino c'est mon ami
mon copain mon compagnon d'armes leone
leonardo gimeno vent journée en un jour
monsieur vous aviez comme on dit au
québec le cac est un peu bas ce matin au
non non non non non c'est normal
moi je dis un vendredi avec un pas trop
d'essence mais mais c'est bien beau
aurait même été le gaz un peu en vue on
veut que vous puissiez me chanter une
chanson mexicaine de warwick est pas en
connaissez-vous m
la mananitas détention
[Musique]
c'est fantastique on les applaudit
alors aujourd'hui notre thème si le
mexique lever la main si vous êtes né au
mexique un moment donné de votre vie bon
je dis oui je sais pas si c'est parce
qu'elle a trop vous est donné au mexique
il ya de cela au moins 22 ans et c'est
gentil mais vous êtes notre vous êtes
deux piliers aujourd'hui l'émission
puisque nous allons parler du mexique
destination mexique l'émission pas
seulement pour parler des choses
économiques et à l'accord de libre
échange qui serait négocie présentement
avec l'oncle tom comme et non look
l'oncle donald voilà et ça va pas très
bien on va garder ça pour plus tard à
l'émission je voulais vous poser ma
première question remue remuez vous les
méninges sa porte sur le mexique
combien de milliers de canadiens on
commence par un petit bout de la
lorgnette se rendre au mexique à tous
les ans par affaire où poussent pour se
divertir sur les plages du mexique
combien me et canadiennes sont chaque
année on et 36 millions canadiens ce
moment on nous avait toujours les bonnes
réponses on a commencé par leonardo
union ouais c'est pas trop mal ça mais
je me demandais le nombre de milliers
ont bien deux millions c'est amélie
10 min on était très fort en maths tous
à l'école alors combien de millions
marie-claude moi je dirais 500 mille
cinq cent mille 500 millions on parle
pas de présence ici on parle de dollars
canadiens alors est ce que c'est le peso
/ mexique
oui je vous dis que je vous posais plein
de questions belle d'aujourd'hui aucune
réponse n'est mauvaises non toutes les
questions sur l'éthique et non c'est mes
questions je bats le droit de le dire
alors vous vous avez la réponse
combien de millions canadiens milliers
des millions deux millions c'est là-bas
de réponse fantastique vous gagnez donc
le prix de l'insolence aujourd'hui
longtemps de ça parce que moi le jeu
connaît rien du mexique je vous dis en
général j'apporte des sujets l'émission
je vous connais tous aujourd'hui je
connais absolument rien sinon que je
perçois quand même des problèmes au
mexique parce que si j'étais j'allais au
mexique pour la question je me poserai
comme touristes c'est éloigne toi pas
trop des centres touristiques comme
acapulco et compagnie parce que tu cours
des risques est-ce que je reste j'aurais
raison pas le mexique c'est un pays qui
est devenu dans les dernières années peu
plus dangereux qui neil qui ne l'a déjà
été par le passé on parle des violences
qui est liée au narcotrafic au trafic
des drogues on parle de violence liés à
la pauvreté
donc je vous dirais que kylie à une
crise en lien avec la violence au
mexique effectivement d'accord mais pas
partout partout mais je pense que c'est
la même chose dans n'importe quel pays
des développements je pars pour
l'argentine que je connais pas trop mais
un peu du pe et un bond à faire c'est la
même chose si tu te promènes pour le
secteur s'est préparé pour le tourisme
n'est pas de problème mais si tu t'en
vas plus loin vers vraiment la vie ils
peuvent peut-être tu peux tomber dans un
des endroits où il ya de la violence je
me rappelle l'année passée ça fait deux
ans et un canadien qui était à buenos
aires puis après en bicyclette puis se
promener par des endroits qui s'était
pas touristique
puis il y avait cent savent sa caméra
oui bien filmé ces îles qu'un il ya une
passion qui est arrivé à moto qui a
commencé à pointer avec un gameplay
d'une vidéo virale là qui nous lui je
vais assister à un bon niveau comme st b
moi j'ai toujours les circuits
touristiques même dans les pays où on
dit toujours à cuba où j'ai jamais si
vous allez à washington avec ça il ya
des endroits où ce vraiment vraiment
délicat c'est à l'extérieur dès le début
de l'après washington dc difficile si tu
connais pas peut-être je vais tomber
dans une embrouille et magasins
cependant je veux juste qu'on on
conclure que j'aurais dit ça il y a 20
ans du mexique depuis une vingtaine
d'années une quinzaine d'années plus tôt
la situation a beaucoup changé au
mexique donc effectivement c'est un pays
qui sait que si on reste dans les coins
touristiques on est correct si on sort
on risque un peu plus même si je veux
pas prendre le point de vue d'une
mexicaine
je vais aller murale prévu d'un canadien
vers quelqu'un vous avez interviewé on
va aller vers la vidéo numéro 2 averti
la tour de contrôle vidéo numéro deux et
non la vidéo 2 millions 1
on a mis la commande on commence alors
prenez le temps alors vous aviez invité
c'était il ya quelques jours ou quelques
mois mois et demi c'est un chercheur
canadien qui vit au mexique
il porte un regard inquiet sur son pays
de sault pays de quitter le pays que
l'arrêt suma tu le car est une
spécialiste canadien de sciences
cognitives
il vit là bas parce que sa femme est
d'origine mexicaine
et voici ce qu'il dit au sujet de cette
nouvelle nouvelle société d'adoption
aidé de ses voisins de ce qu'ils pensent
par rapport à cette question de la
sécurité
3 4 2 6 on est prêt
[Musique]
une chose moi c'est grande préoccupation
pour la sécurité
j'ai entendu des histoires comme j'en
avais jamais entendu je le connais
directement les amis à moi ou à mon
beau-frère qui ont été attaqués à main
qui ont été volés en mer mais dans des
étudiants un jour j'ai une étudiant qui
est arrivants store à l'examen n'a pas
pu prendre en examen parce que l'autobus
80 provenaient la ligne ft d'attaquer et
ça c'est sûr que le pays ne va pas bien
et je sais un peu plus long aussi parce
que mon pauvre poste très impliqué dans
la vie quotidienne de la ville y avait
des gens vraiment terrible le trafic
d'organes trafic de personnes dans cette
question delà des soucis par rapport à
la violence à la sécurité au mexique
ça rejaillit sur le canada parce qu'on
peut pas parler du mexique tout seul
dans son bain il ya aussi la nation du
canada après tout c'est un des voisins
lointains du canada et il n'ya pas
pierre elliott trudeau pop non justin
trudeau qui se trouvait il ya une
dizaine de jours au mexique pour
rencontrer son homologue où ils ont
parlé beaucoup d'économies mais pas du
tout la question des droits humains et
ça a choqué beaucoup de chance ça a
choqué beaucoup de monde ces pandas
monsieur trop d'eau a quand même
mentionné devant le sénat mexicain qu'il
y avait une crise au niveau de respect
des droits des femmes
donc il a fait un parallèle avec les
problématiques des droits de femmes au
canada et il a dit le mexique il ya du
travail affamés au delà de ça il y en a
pas beaucoup qui a été mentionné logo
mais barrios qui est avec nous de la
section espagnole de radio canada
international
un de nos invités mystères vous
connaissez le jeu manceau paloma et
comment connaît connexion l'acte i ni
les collectionnent latine ici
aujourd'hui les tableaux vous avez vous
êtes intéressé à la visite d'une
délégation mexicaine au canada cette
semaine qui repart vendredi vers le
mexique
il venait parler de cette question très
délicate des droits de la personne mais
aussi du sort des journalisme les
journalistes
le quatrième pouvoir au mexique et le
problème exactement bon un peu les
problèmes il est grave il faut le dire
en partant est en vue on va regarder
l'article que pablo a fait cette semaine
pendant qu'il nous explique le dossier
la vidéo numéro 3 et banque et j'ai eu
la chance de parler
une journaliste mexicaine qui fait
partie de cette délégation là elle fait
partie d'un groupe de journalistes
mexicaines qui s'appelle journalistes d
appuyer et à piller donc c'est un
organisme au mexique qui bons qui sont
vraiment très concerné par toute cette
violation des droits humains au mexique
et le daniela pastrana qui fait partie
de ces groupes là elle nous parlait dit
c'est que depuis l'an 2000 il ya eu
environ 110 journalistes qui ont été
assassinés et 24 24 on en recense faire
disparu donc et c'est cette situation
qui tous les défenseurs des droits
humains estiment qui est très difficile
et leur présence ici c'était justement
pour conscience y ait six vous on veut
faire prendre conscience aux
parlementaires et aux politicienne mais
les canadiens sur la situation des
droits humains au mexique en particulier
avec les journalistes
on pense que dans le cadre des
négociations de la menace et c'est
important de mettre le phare pleins feux
sur ce genre sur ce problème de
l'assassinât des journalistes ont dit
que si une occasion là ici de
sensibiliser d'aller plus loin dans la
sensibilisation est demandé l'un du
canada enfin ce que le premier ministre
ya pas longtemps au mexique dans lé
cadre justement de
de cette négociation de l'échangé des
traités de libre-échange nord-américain
la ligne en français et puis eux ils se
disent que le canada se préoccupe
vraiment beaucoup plus pour les accords
commerciaux est très peu pour le respect
des droits humains
c'est juste pour te donner quelques
quelques chiffres et on dit on on dit
que au mexique le mexique imminent les
12e et pays et bleu plus qu'ils allaient
plus de victimes un terme des conflits
et puis avec 23000 personnes assassinées
en 2016 seulement et puis plus de 180
mille personnes qui sont décédées depuis
2006 donc et c'est cette situation qui
est assez très grave
et puis eux ils dénoncent cette
situation l'appui des mangles au canada
justement des faire quelque chose et non
seulement ils disent que le canada a
beaucoup fait pour aider les victimes
des tremblements de terre qu'il ya eu au
mexique dernièrement mais qui fait très
peu pour le respect des droits humains
au mexique là que le premier ministre
s'est rendu en chine aussi puis là à
l'exception d'un discours il n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de cette question
publiquement des droits de la personne
ce qu'il était en chine on dirait qu'on
fait le commerce avant tout et on
reprend donc un vieux thème du parti
conservateur
les conservateurs qui étaient là avant
eux bien sûr la diplomatie c'est le
commerce pas rater je mets un peu
l'action un autre des membres de la
délégation mexicaine qui étaient ici au
mexique sans avoir à l'ireq qui est
directeur adjoint du centre pour les
droits de la personne miel agustin
pourquoi reste au mexique était une
conférence de presse
ici à ottawa il y a dix un nombre
ahurissant d' atrocités sont commises en
toute impunité au mexique il n'y à pas
l'enquêté encore moins de justice il a
aussi ajouté
nous avons apprécié la réunion avec le
premier ministre canadien pour discuter
de ce cas mais l'appui du canada
peut-être plus important encore donc ça
c'est le message qu'ils ont qui ont
amené ce local au canada ses tableaux
oui j'aimerais ajouter un autre des
personnes qui faisaient partie de cette
délégation là s'appelle gustavo lozano
qui est membre d'une région mexicaine
des communautés affectées pas
l'exploitation des mines au mexique
et puis ils disent qu'ils sont vraiment
troublé par le silence du canada par
rapport à la destruction que ces
compagnies minières la forme au mexique
et par la violation des droits humains
dans ces régions là donc il ya
particulier par les compagnies minières
d'un certain état mexicaine compagnies
minières canadiennes sont libres les
plus grandes scènes qui investissent le
plus dans le monde en numéro 1 h épées
tenant à londres par des sociétés à
numéro très souvent je vraiment entendre
deux points vie des canadiens maintenant
exactement parce que c'est cette
délégation a été amenée ici au canada
par le conseil canadien pour la
coopération internationale
donc il s'appelle bourassa avec qui j'ai
eu la chance de parler dit le canada
doit établir des balises claires
concernant la présence des minières
canadiennes à l'étranger
particulièrement dans ce cas au mexique
donc c'était très intéressant de
converser la défense de conversation
avec elle ce sont encore plus
intéressantes note en deux temps en
temps quelques conversations que vous
avez eue
et voici donc notre vidéo du jour la
vidéo numéro 4
c'est certain que ça a été un moment
très important et les représentants des
organismes de la société civile
mexicaine ont beaucoup apprécié le fait
de pouvoir se réunir avec le premier
ministre canadien
un message que le premier ministre
lançait que la question des droits
humains est importante pour le canada
par contre le message assez unanimes que
nous représentons ici ont lancé que le
canada doit faire plus pour pour
répondre à cette crise des droits
humains et doivent faire pression sur le
gouvernement mexicain
on suit que le canada a des accords dans
la corde là les nains entre autres et
beaucoup de lit d'abord une source très
très très concrète que le gouvernement
pourrait faire c'est se doter d'un homme
goody mène indépendant pour le secteur
extractif de cette façon là il y aurait
des mécanismes d'une enquête il y aurait
des mesures législatives qui pourraient
faire en sorte que les compagnies
minières canadiennes qui ont des
comportements en violation des droits
humains à l'étranger ton au mexique
ferait très réprimandé seraient punis y
aurait lioret il y aura des recours
légaux contrer ces compagnies là et ils
l'ont bout du ventre en mesure de faire
enquête pour déterminer qu'est ce qui se
passe actuellement le canada note
yannick mécanisme volontariat pour les
entreprises minières
il ya un commissaire à la responsabilité
corporative qui est l'homme et qui n'a
pas de moyens financiers qui n'a pas de
moyens légaux pour s'assurer que ce qui
est des mesures qui soient prises donc
nous la société civile canadienne
on est on est unanime on dit bon le
canada pourrait prendre toutes mesures
concrètes la de plus dans tout ce qui
est diplôme ainsi et bilatérales ans au
canada et le mexique le canada pourrait
faire davantage pression avoir des
mécanismes de surveillance de ce qui se
passe au mexique et à travers toutes les
mécanismes de glo massy entre les deux
états il pourrait y avoir davantage de
pressions de la part du canada
alors c'est pas tout on a de la visite
deuxième invité mystère qui s'est glissé
un peu comme le jambon dans la salle
which je suis jambon gros jambon à
marivan bonjour devrait toujours
toujours toujours un plaisir de vous
laisser avec de l'amour douleur officiel
[Musique]
vous êtes là parce que vous avez ajouté
à la conversation dans un instant vous
avez fait des reportages beaucoup
intéressé à au mexique à travers je me
promène entre deux micros c'est bien
c'est bien pour elle mais c'est pas bien
méchant talent mais puisqu'on est
touriste tous réunis vous êtes 5
c'est merveilleux on n'a jamais eu ce ce
nombre trois micros et cinq personnes
j'ai une petite question la question
remue-méninges numéro 2 les milieux de
moi j'arrive pour la question remue
ménage et le reste et le dessert nature
d'accord alors vrai ou faux c'est une
question vrai ou faux le 5 1 % de
chances de la bande à voir c'est facile
on a déjà 50%
le dhc les examens d'école est fait
comme ça
vrai ou faux au moment de la signature
de la laine de la léo lalune ah oui en
1988 il y avait quatre pays signataires
quatre pays signataires au vent de la
signature parce que c'est faux vous moi
je pense que c'est faux j'avais juste
trois pays les états unis le mexique et
le canada corp marie-claude vrai vrai
saint pierre et miquelon un gosse alors
à ce territoire français peut-être pas
demain je dirais faux faux son quai et
vous leonardo but
vous les vrais seulement pour faire de
la contre alors nous je dire le belize
belize ce pays comme ça qu'il est et non
l'américain blessé plus que trois pays
la france
vous avez raison il ya quatre pays dont
en amérique du nord enfin la france un
petit bout de présence ici à saint
pierre et miquelon
dans les faits il n'y avait que deux
pays ce à quoi je m'attendais pas 4
pancartes non plus juste de ce que vous
êtes confus c'est très facile stèle
canada les etats-unis qui ont d'abord
signé une entente
ensuite ils ont élargi ça et c'est
devenu le mexique qui s'est joint à la
fête
d'accord au départ c'étaient les allées
ces états unis et le canada
mais ça c'est un traître nous ne traiter
que les gauches traité bilatéral ses
deux pilotes prenaient ensuite les ont
décidé d'intégrer le mexique là dedans
c'est là qu'ils deviennent la ligne oui
mais
c'était c'était penser comme ça triki
libéral peux pas m'empêcher de rire
c'est comme si thil professeurs et les
élèves sont complètement et disciplinés
on a bien compris la leçon là la réponse
est faux c'était deux pays et puis 3
l'alena comment dire en espagnol l'alena
t elle
telle qu'elle est laissée à une telle
can tell qui se joue ici c'est comme
traité de libre commerce de l'amérique
du nord
si on avait juste un accord seulement
hors des peuples quand même pour les
françaises sont en avait seulement un
accord avec le canada et le mexique ça
s'appellerait commun à l'espagnol le
traité de l'amitié peut-être en france
elle est ensuite traitée d
des logos amigos sociale et trois amis
le ménage avait des deux amis came
clarification est ce que le mexique est
considéré en amérique du nord à partir
de la moitié du territoire d'ailleurs le
sud du mexique fait partie de l'amérique
centrale pratiquement parlant ni le nord
à partir de la ville de mexico et au
bernabeu partie de l'amérique du nord
habituellement c'est officiellement le
mexique fait partie de l'amérique du
nord
on en apprend des choses aujourd'hui moi
qui connaissait que les plages du
mexique face à ces conditions comme ça
non plus et les canadiens devraient
connaître plus que les plages parce que
quand on connaît c'est ça le contexte
politique sociale au mexique c'est très
important nous en tant que canadien
lorsqu'on se rend au mexique de
comprendre l'autre réalité celle que
l'on ne voit jamais qu'on ne veut
peut-être même pas voir un il faut aussi
mentionner et stéphane et amérique le
mexique autour de la signature du traité
de libre échange en fait de l'accord de
libre échange
il y a eu beaucoup de critiques de la
part des déjà de la société civile
mexicain des politiciens au mexique
il semblait être un traité
il ya un accord y inégale et inéquitable
donc parce que le mexique est une
économie forte
certes mais il est une économie qui est
différente à celle du canada et celle de
ses états unis et le sac de
l'agriculture particulièrement le
secteur agricole m'excitait aïda eu des
grains problème et continue d'avoir de
grands problèmes parce que il n'est pas
ce n'est pas une industrie
enfin il ce n'est pas une industrie tout
court ya pas d n'y a pas d'industrie
lisation de l'agriculture au mexique
c'est fait par des des peptides et
petite famille qui font ça de la façon
la plus traditionnelle et dernièrement
oui dans le nord du mexique à un peu
plus industralisés à sion du secteur
agroalimentaire mais au début des
échanges de lettres du traité c'était
vraiment différent les façons de
fonctionner les industries étaient
complètement inégale
en fait le mexique est perdant dans
cette partie de l'agroalimentaire parce
que l'agroalimentaire est subventionnée
au canada et aux etats unis alors qu'au
mexique ça ne l'est pas c'est quoi le
résultat des saints ce que maintenant
des produits comme le blé maïs et comme
les faibles qui sont des produits de
première nécessité au mexique et le
producteur les producteurs mexicains qui
produit ces c'est dangereux là
auparavant se trouve à faire la
compétition avec du maïs et des faire
subventionner de l'amérique du nord
alors mettez vous à la place de paysans
des gens des mexicains qui ont des bas
revenus qui arrive au marché et là on a
du maïs qui viennent des états unis et
du canada à un prix x et puis le prix
les minces et
les fèves mexicaine qui sont plus chers
donc pas ce que sont pas subventionnées
alors ils vont acheter les produits les
moins chers mais est-ce que je pense que
jamais on s'est posé ces questions -
comme jamais je me suis posée est ce que
les mecs qui veulent quand même cet
accord de l'alena où ils veulent
renégocier quelque chose qui serait plus
en leur faveur parce que c'est ce que
les américains demandent
on ne peut pas répondre à cette question
parce que c'est comme c'est un peu vague
au niveau de la réponse gouvernementale
en ce moment ce qu'on sait c'est que le
mexique se prépare pour une éventuelle
rupture complète de cet accord une
aubaine dont absolu de cet accord le
président mexicain était dernièrement en
chine il a discuté des ddc change
possible de ses exportations de ses
importations il est allé aussi en
argentine il a établi des liens plus
forts avec certaines pays de l'amérique
latine
donc le mexique s'est préparée par aaa
n'a pas au divorce avec les états unis
le canada et le canada
pour balma qu'il y aura comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure un accord
bilatéral comme cette les relations
canado-américaines existe depuis très
longtemps de relations diplomatiques des
relations commerciales
ce n'est pas nouveau pour le canada et
le mexique de faire quelque chose d
d'une idée conjointe 1 100 commandes du
mariage en espagnol cette relation-là
canada mexique et qui s'est ouvert les
forces d'une certaine façon
après la révolution cubaine en 1959
parce que le canada et le mexique
ce furent les seuls pays de la planète
qui ont peur en plus des relations
diplomatiques avec cuba
donc il y avait déjà dix ans cette
complicité
c'est à dire écoutez on pourrait
poursuivre on devrait poursuivre mais je
vais faire un tour de table
on va venir maintenant aux états unis et
après sans voir tourner au mexique une
dernière fois en accord avec un
compatriote même peut-être deux si on a
le temps voir avec la tour de contrôle
est ici présente les honorio répondent à
notre question tam-tam cette semaine
quels seraient selon vous les
conséquences en amérique du nord d'un
mur au mexique à la donne en troupeau
est ce un mur
à la donne en croûte aux états unis je
ne sais pas on va mettre le mur est ce
qu'on veut la plus du côté américain et
mu était déjà là il est déjà en fait il
était déjà là dans l'époque
obama en si c'était pas si grand que
ceux qui veulent notre métier talent pas
si l'on sait pas si longue
mais quand même me est là mais ça change
pas beaucoup en fait ça va charger des
ddd des chaussées frontalière la dent
proche de la frontière
ils savent à empêcher les gens qui
veulent rentrer illégalement au pays
on ne sait pas on trouve toujours le
moyen elle marie ce que ça va changer
quand quelque chose un mur entre les
deux nations
hélas non je crois que ça ne changera
rien non plus les etats unis sont très
intransigeant ils ont déjà des lois et
des politiques qui désavantage les
mexicains de l'autre côté alors déjà au
départ même sens le mur c'est difficile
mais le mur je pense n'y changera pas
grand chose
marie-claude vous y croyez au mur croix
rouge
oui mais je crois que des mois je crois
aux fenêtres
de toute façon une frontière ok alors
dès le départ qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attention médiatique sur cette espèce
de déclarations de monsieur trompe mais
ça nous empêche peut-être de vraiment
cette fois vraiment réfléchir ou vrai
problème parce que je pense alors on va
couper court à cette conversation
non mais moi j'ai quelque chose à dire
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
changer depuis depuis que ce mur a
commencé à être construit parce que les
murs etc si la construction du mur des
dates de quelques clics les styles que
ce n'est déjà rien exactement
depuis que ça a été construit les morts
les migrants qui essayent de traverser
la frontière pour qu'ils se confrontent
à plus de plus en plus d'obstacle et qui
prennent les plus petits chemins les
plus jeunes les chemins les plus cachés
c'est mettre leur vie un risque et ça ça
veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup plus d
des décès liés à ces assauts sept
principes migratoires donc ça va changer
ça parce que les manières de traverser
vont être toujours plus difficile est
toujours dangereux si on traverse des
algériens ont ses pairs d'un dessert et
je savais que bon ça s'est bien passé
c'était un problème entre humains en
font des guerres entre nations
j'aimerais vous amener vers un sujet qui
intéresse beaucoup aidé mari vont à bon
et on a parlé au moins peut-être deux
reprises peut-être 3 2 puis 3 1 et celle
on pourrait dire que c'est quelque chose
qui est un truc qui peut changer le
monde c'est un on parle d'un voyageur
qui se promène entre le canada et le
mexique chaque année on parle d'une
migration les papillons monarques parce
que les ailes des papillons peuvent tout
changer
il passe par dessus tout les murs qui
peuvent exister
à propos des murs j'avais juste une
information que je voulais vous donner
vous savez il n'ya pas juste des murs là
actuellement entre le canada entre le
mexique et les etats-unis n'a pas su
comment y en a partout dans le monde et
y en a tellement que si l'eau si l'on
mettait bout à bout tous ces murs on
ferait le tour de la planète
on pourrait sans murs et tous même à
travers les océans il y aurait des murs
oui il ya suffisamment de briques
partout à travers le monde
il ya déjà deux murs existants c'est bon
de les collectionner des briques du mur
de berlin
s'il y avait vraiment de murs dans des
seaux science ça serait bien parce que
sa barre et tenir les ouragans cesser
les barrières des co rie et servent de
certaines façons que des premières
barrières quand les sous la gorge et les
poissons on voit les protéger maintenant
ils seraient coincés des poissons ils
peuvent plus voyager librement les
papillons les poissons voilà pour les
poissons ont fait des petits tunnels
bon ce peuple les choses sérieuses oui
le retour des papillons monarques qu'on
croyait disparaître mais il semblerait
que les listings maintenant c'est qu'il
ya une renaissance en sang neuf
le renouveau on renaît de ses cendres du
côté des papillons monarques et on a
réalisé cette entrevue avec une
spécialiste au jardin botanique de
montréal
on va se quitter là dessus lorsqu'il
était bébé sur l'ensemble de l'amérique
du nord à l'est des rocheuses qui la
population compte qui est la plus
importante et bien c'est à peu près
impossible de pouvoir évaluer sa classe
sa taille mais lorsqu'ils se retrouvent
sur quelques sommets de montagnes au
mexique
c'est l'excellent moment de devenir et
de d'évaluer l'ampleur de la population
et ce qui se fait à chaque année par nos
collègues mexicains et les chiffres
vient tout juste de sortir pour cette
année et on a une excellente nouvelle on
est très content
la population qui était extrêmement
préoccupante a bondi nous étions l'année
dernière à 1.13 hectares de superficie
couverte par les monarques l'année
d'avant c'était la population la plus
faible
on n'était même pas un hectare on était
à point 67 ha de superficie couverte par
les monarques donc on était vraiment
très très inquiet et cette année nous
avons atteint le bon chiffre de 4 points
1 hectare alors le papillon monarque
c'est un fait un essai qui est vraiment
fascinant c'est un pollinisateur
important mais c'est aussi un emblème
pour tous les autres pollinisateurs
puisque ceux qui toussent la monaque
touche également les autres qui sont
moins connus qui sont moins des figures
emblématiques
alors voilà c'est tout pour cette
semaine c'est tout c'est tout c'est tout
la semaine prochaine je pourrai jouer
devinez quoi au sujet de la semaine
prochaine s'est déjà fixé on a déjà deux
invités sur skype des spécialistes
l'halloween mais ça aurait été
magnifique
oui on est tellement proche en même
temps qu'on pourrait venir déguisé par
hasard de l'animateur en petite chinoise
c'est là dans la fin je me suis déguisé
comme un cas bien petit chemin je peux
aller très loin
[Rires]
bompas fait pas tellement fière de moi
que tu fais là
écoutez la semaine prochaine ses
développements économiques
internationales non c'est le célèbre du
canada en afrique
pas partout autour de la planète ce
serait trop beau mais en afrique et
c'est beaucoup plus réduit depuis
quelques années même sous un
gouvernement qui se dit libéral
voilà c'est mon commentaire de la
semaine paloma martino
merci beaucoup merci à vous pablo merci
infiniment d'être venu comme un de nos
invités mystères cette semaine pablo
gomez et puis marie claude simard notre
webmestre vous ne touchez à rien tout va
bien pardon c'est très bien tout coeur
les autres
la semaine prochaine c'est passé c'est
moi qui ait touché puis ça peut aller
bien dans la première minute faut jamais
avouer ses fautes en général la cale
votre patron vous dit vous faites une
erreur faudrait de la wii non faute
avouée est à moitié pardonnée quand même
moitié pardonnée arrivons on va suivre
votre conseil pendant au moins deux
semaines voir ce qui se produit ici